okay
uh welcoming people to the second live
stream of today
uh we are talking about chemistry
functionality for version 12.2
people might be noticing a theme that
version 12.2 is approaching
and we're increasing the number of
design review live streams so many more
to come even another one today i think
all right uh let me go ahead and try and
run this let's hope that works
it's grinding a lot
that's a lot what's it doing is it gonna
hang
it's mostly handshaking and getting the
things
okay great okay
molecule draw on earth is this
many people want to sketch one but jason
you are much more expert
so uh chemists i mean uh typically like
to
to draw a molecule wow
what is this this is mine uh it needs a
lot of work aesthetically i
uh let's see the dynamics is not my
forte but it it currently works we just
we need to get a lot of feedback before
oh is it more time entered yeah oh
that's not the right ux
i mean that that it's got to have some
dragging
thing go on but that's interesting okay
so at this point you could click redraw
the button on the bottom
and you'll see that that's cool
okay who's going to help with this ux
so that's that's the smile string that i
just generated right
right right and you can type uh into the
if i do this
what happens if i if i select that and i
then do that
that should yeah make a double bond
you can select an atom and then hover
and then change an atom type
no i can't because i've got to get
preset no look
look look see that how can i ux wise go
over here
right see what i'm saying if i pick
phosphorus and then i click that atom
then great i've got phosphorus there see
what i'm saying
so it's it's taken out do we have
anybody from ux here
best person to look at this would be
noah um
i mean this looks very promising but i
think the ux
is very confusing this is a say what
you're going to do then do it
type ux right which is kind of not what
people
are used to these days i mean there are
plenty of them out there and i think it
was mostly modeled
after existing ones okay
what are these what's that doesn't
happen
zoom yeah i need a mouse over right i
need uh
so that zoom in and zoom out
that shouldn't be there that should be
somehow on the on the canvas
did you understand what i'm saying yes
let me start right now
and that's a that's a um that's already
a pattern that we have
for things like geo um dynamic
geographics already has a plus minus
zoom button that's visible in the canvas
i will go i will look at that and
after that okay uh
so i think here
i would say if you're really going to do
this specify it then do it you want this
on the left hand side
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
um
but i don't know um because this this
seems like a modifier
and you know so so really
is that really a thing quantitative
barrier
they're more common in organic chemistry
than organic chemistry but they are
quite frequent
so for tho for both the atom and the
bond i just don't know how to do this
but i think ideally you would have one
button
that shows the currently the current
atom type the new atom type and a click
and hold
would pull up the entire periodic table
then you just reach over and select
which one you want and
there's just one button for a bond and
you click and hold and it pulls up the
list of all the bot
the types of bonds i just don't know how
to do that at the moment
you know how to implement it or you
don't know how to do the ux for it i
don't know how to implement uh
okay but that's a different thing do you
understand the ux that you want to
achieve
yes okay i like that have you been
working with somebody in the front end
team to actually do this
no okay we need to do that lou
or kevin or somebody like that okay so
tell them what you want to achieve
and see if they can tell you how to
achieve it yeah
okay so so essentially what you're
saying is
you click something i don't know what
i'm doing here so now what on earth is
that doing
so you just added a disconnected atom
right because i'm in the mode where i'm
adding atoms you know
look noah just spent like six months
working on our drawing tools
please talk to him okay okay
and and if you need me to be in that
meeting i can be there but but
but you know this looks yeah you should
learn what he's done
okay um
one metal question that we discussed is
should it bring up something new or
should it be something in the
notebook that stays there
i don't know and i don't know what's
implementationally possible right now
um i think it should do whatever
i don't know what create canvas does
it doesn't even implement it supposed to
do it should do the same thing that that
does that is the drawing tools analog of
this
do you understand what i'm saying
this needs to be integrated with drawing
tools okay you apparently haven't talked
to anybody who's dealing with that
that's where it needs to go that's not
quite true like
this comes basically before the geometry
will split off into the molecule and the
geometry
and before we had many meetings
activists know about it
okay well fine fine good i mean this
looks very close
it's just got you know details that are
wrong
and which will make it less much less
usable
yeah i mean it's just totally unclear
what to do at this point here
right that's just i just it's completely
unclear you you've set
carbon as the default here for some
random reason
see what i'm saying yeah
yeah but in in jason's defense stephen
carbon is what
chemists typically draw with for the
most part so having that be the first
choice is
reasonable whatever but i mean it's
the state of this is just utterly
confusing this is an afterthought it's
on the right
it's it's just no it's wrong okay we'll
we'll work with the
uh front-end team come for the bill and
noah
because he's the one who's thought about
drawing tools ux
okay and then i i'd like to i mean this
looks like very very useful
functionality and not far away from
being
really good but like the drawing tools
which for 20 years have languished
in the category of not quite there this
has the habit of you know this will do
the same thing unless we get it right
okay so okay
so these don't have uh futurize doc
pages yet but i
so i just wanted to verify that i can
add these in
uh oh this is finding something
yeah that that seems reasonable but i
mean this is
like this should work like edge style
does in plots right
yeah so it should allow you to
style specific atoms and also uh
how does edge style work edge style
basically
tells you in edge style you give it
a well this will be vertex style right
what you would do
is vertex style would let you give a
list of
rules of the form vertex goes to
whatever okay so that's exactly what you
don't mean plot you mean cough float
i meant graph actually okay yeah right
this is exactly what that does so that's
good so that's either a name of a vertex
or it's a class of vertices here right
yes
what does that mean so
i mean so that's that's something that
can be used right currently in like fine
molecule substructure
or molecules what does that mean
i mean so it just means to find a carbon
or nitrogen with
at least one hydrogen attached
i i don't understand this this bug this
selection bug is still here i've
reported it like every day for the last
two weeks
yeah i i also i yeah
it's been around for since we switched
to 12.2 i feel like and
but yeah
um okay that looks good that atom style
thing looks good
right and then the one that that i
haven't even
done yet but uh that let's see that
brace there is wrong right
oh no no that i see i'm sorry that's the
outer brace yeah right
go ahead yes um so the uh um the shape
functions
so to to allow users to really just put
in
any kind of arbitrary shape for an atom
or for a bond
so we don't currently have any any
mechanism for
putting it it's common in these when you
write a paper or something to put
just a ph there to signify that there's
a phenyl group
we don't currently support that in our
data structure but if the user wants to
create that for a visualization that's
what the
the atom shape function would be used
for
but it's not just an atom
so it's not an atom shape it's it's a
that's
a whole how do you specify that whole
group being substituted that way
so so in that case the user would just
create a dummy atom and give it
an atom shape function of ph
but what if they actually want it to be
an actual phenyl group
that they just want the phenyl group to
be displayed in its aggregated form like
this
so that's that's a more complicated
uh we are discussing this in a couple
weeks
because that's something which has come
up also in system modeler right and
system model they have this notion of
hierarchical structures
how do they handle it
do you understand what i'm asking right
so
in that case you know you can have this
can be a you know
an op-amp or something and and that
appears as a single blob
at one level and then you can click down
and see it inside
so that seems to me to be the model that
you want here right because you
you might want to you know in general i
don't know how hierarchical it gets in
chemistry
how hierarchical does it get well so so
when we do
it's going to we're going to need to go
to having a macromolecule data structure
to connect between this work
and what john is doing and there having
a hierarchical
plotting function is going to be
indispensable
um okay looking at things as ribbons
versus scaling uh zoom yeah i understand
i understand so we need a pattern then
for dealing with something which is a
higher level
visualization right which has aggregated
certain things
it's not just visualization like you
also won't say to prescribe
molecular weights and other properties
of the sink okay fine so so what you've
got is a wrapper
that represents so this ph thing would
be
some kind of uh wrapper that says
this is actually a ph but inside is all
this stuff
right so so it's come up in the in the
meetings uh people in the group have
wanted uh some type of super atom and so
i was trying to
slide this in just as a visualization
but if we want to do
some type of super atom then i then it's
going to require more uh
more thoughts yeah i think i think it
requires more thought i mean yeah and
uh i like the hierarchical aspect as
well that we could nest it as deeply as
we wanted to
right yep let's go that way jason
i mean and and then then whatever the
super atom is
um what would we call that thing what
would it be called in chemistry it's not
really a chemical group
because that's something more specific
what is it a moiety
yeah moiety would be a proper term for
it
i think our group would be it would be a
perfectly fine one
as well yeah but our group is from the
organic side the the inorganic community
uses ligands
why it is the neutral between the two
communities
more general so i would go with that
which one
moiety nobody's ever heard of it
well chemists have chemists have i still
think
our group is going to have uh it's got a
nice name
and all chemists would uh
even inorganic chemists i think would
understand what it's supposed to
be strange if it's something in the
middle that has multiple things going
out
wouldn't it yes
usually our groups have single hapticity
they're only at the end but not in the
middle
correct yeah moiety's gonna be better
it's a really freaking weird word yeah
agreed i
i thought it was too when i took organic
chemistry but it's
been around for ages yeah it's in the
so i will tell you that if you look up
in a dictionary the first
things you see are anthropological terms
about each of two parts into which a
thing can be divided
in law
i have never heard of this in chemistry
well
it has a so quite frankly i think
atom could be used for it the the symbol
atom is
near upon useless i mean it it can
it it has one purpose representing an
atom inside a molecule or as a pattern
um so it
it could substituent is that a is that a
term
that is a term yeah
but again it tends to imply just a
single
connection right
okay well i think moyety is too weird a
word
amusing but weird well unfortunately the
whole field of chemistry disagrees
it's more than two million google
scholar hits really
well yeah i'm wrong yeah
some of my live streaming tar is
suggesting superstructure
um there are various people here are
commenting that that
ligand's more common with polymers and r
groups more common with organic
um
superstructures are an equivalence class
many molecules have identical
function
um
yeah pi is commenting that when you say
r subgroup it's like using
the word x to represent a variable
the r is what you would put in as the
thing in the diagram
typically right yep in the inorganic
community yes
right well okay so there's a name in
question here and it's
i don't think atom is going to cut it i
think that's too confusing
to have an atom that's a whole amino
acid or something
unfortunately that suggests like it's
part extraction
go ahead what were you saying just so
with these molecules up above where they
have a ph
i mean those should exist ju they should
be
in the all atom representation when
they're in the molecule
they should be expanded and there should
be a visualization option
for contracting them and displaying them
i agree ph or something
but i agree yeah i i don't uh
let's see so if we moving to a place
where we represent entire substructures
as um as symbolic pieces
there's a lot that would need to go into
well what i'm suggesting is
that in your molecular structure right
you have a wrapper around i mean what
you've got right now is a list of atoms
and bonds
in here right so the issue is
if you wrapped that okay there's a
there's a bit of a problem here but
but the naive thing to do would be to
wrap that list of atoms and bonds
with some wrapper that means this is a a
chemical substructure thing
moiety whatever you call it right
but the problem with that is that it has
bonds hanging out of it
and it's not clear go ahead yeah well so
i've
let's see so we have these things we've
discussed um uh the the idea of um
hyper edges right with so we have these
things uh
stereo groups which is a collection of
five atoms or a collection of four atoms
and we say specifically that they have
such and such relationship
in 3d space specifically with
tetrahedral centers we'll say that
these four atoms are situated around
this fifth atom in such a way
that the signed volume when taken in
this order is positive or negative
that i have uh been thinking
and uh building the case slowly that uh
that should
extend to be a third argument where you
have atoms
bonds and then groups
which can be stereo groups this is the
ones we support
stereo groups that we don't currently
support which bob has been interested in
among other people types of
stereochemistry that we don't currently
support
and it could also include um
elited groups or some something that we
want
to indicate that these atoms which you
find in
list one which also have bonds that you
found in list two
they are a substructure and we put them
in this
this list of hyper edges or
whatever word we want to use to describe
it
but that that's only one level deep then
you couldn't actually nest that
yeah which is right i don't i don't i
don't know this nesting sounds like a
lot of work
and well let's find out what system
modeler does and see how they handle it
right because
this is exactly they have exactly the
same issue they have effectively bonds
hanging out
in fact even i think their
representation is a so-called bond graph
yeah right so i know several people
in in yan's group so let me talk with
them okay
okay let's let's keep going here but but
adam style and bond style both look fine
somehow i i have this view of never mind
um okay
simplifying the concept of using
implicit hydrogens
and gaza doesn't have the hydrogens in
its internal representation
yes i agree with that statement
right right now our data structure we
rely
we make use of a lot of chem informatics
tools and i think that this
may have overly influenced the data
structure that we
use and so um so in a smile string which
comes from the world of chem informatics
just c
is methane yeah right um but this
is counter-intuitive to our users though
i think
right so what we would still interpret
the smile string
of c as methane and the smile string of
o
as oxygen or as water but when you
put that inside a list like this i agree
i think that's utterly confusing it'd
just be an oxygen atom
and so then after this change the
functions add hydrogen and remove
hydrogens
would instead of what they currently do
which is convert between implicit and
explicit
they would convert between hydrogens
and um hairs
or yeah unpaired electrons or
what exactly when you remove the
hydrogens what's left over
what's left over is something which in
the molecule representation
is just a naked c for example
right and it would have with its go
ahead if you ask how many unpaired
electrons did that
uh have then the naked c would would
tell you it had four
how do you ask for the number of
unpaired electrons um i believe it's a
molecule property unpaired electron
count
okay um
well i agree this makes more sense
and so the what this means is that users
who create
molecule expressions in 12.0 or 12.1
um and then read them back in in 12.2
if they did not call set options include
hydrogens goes to true
which they will not have done then uh
the molecules
when read into 12.2 could be
different well so so let's understand
how that works
so what's the case where it's different
well the case where it's different
is this case here
right where somebody put that in
so if they had generated a molecule
let's say they generated let's say that
they put in methane as a molecule so
they said molecule
okay what is that
so that's fine that's got explicit
hydrogens in it
right right yep so if they
create a molecule of um methane and
include hydrogens goes to false no no i
i understand i understand i understand
that i understand that what i'm trying
to understand is
if they did it from entities they will
have no problem
right true the case where they will have
trouble
is where and i'm sure we've got examples
of this kind where somebody just did
you know table
okay so let me understand what will
happen here so if i say table
c five then and i just say molecule of
that
the question is do i get pentane or
whatever it is or do i get
garbage there you get five disconnected
methane molecules
but that's not the and in the future
you'll get five disconnected carbon
atoms
how do i make that a bond right so then
um
so then the second argument would be um
you know bond
slash at you know so i mean
no no no no no okay so you're saying
i see this is different from like string
join
of table c5 which would give the smile
string
which will then like as
now as before would generate something
with added hydrogens right
although in let's see the expression
there the
hydrogens are left implicit they are not
in it and therein lies the the trouble
oh that's not gonna work that's not
gonna work
okay okay so so
what do you know okay that's gonna be a
disaster
okay so let's figure out how we back out
of this
right so let's look at the expressions
you get from smile strings
right do you understand what i'm asking
i'm saying i think you're going to get
you'll be going to be able to have some
clue
from the fact that it's something that
has all of this stuff filled in all this
bond information filled in
aren't you going to be able to get
different information here
so in 12.2 where we would know so in
12.2 we wouldn't uh
let's see we would look at that and we
would say this user clearly wanted to
create
a a chain of five carbon atoms without
hydrogens
i understand i'm asking you given what
you see here
right is there at least a heuristic that
would tell you was this generated from a
smile string
as opposed to did somebody type this in
did you understand what i'm asking i
know the the expressions
i understand that you can in principle
get the same expression
right
right i'm just saying that the the
currently the code
i understand you can in principle type
in the same expression that's not the
question i'm asking
there's no history go ahead what there's
no history so you cannot know
that it comes from smiles or something
else guys guys
guys how about some thinking here that's
not what steven is asking
right thank you michael right i think
the hint would be
that as the expression that comes here
is as
ordered as possible
yes i think a human might do something
slightly different from time to time
well and among other things this
canonicalizes
the fact that this has atom wrappers
around the seas
is that a hint or does that happen in
other words a user who typed this in
if i typed in just c c like this
how does that canonicalize oh it doesn't
even have the bond information
but how does that canonicalize it does
it does right
put in the animators all right okay okay
okay our goal is the following
for version 12.2 but not thereafter to
be able to put a warning
that indicates that
heuristically you know this might be not
what you think it is
i mean heuristically i would assume the
vast majority
of users will have such will have all
bond saturated by hydrogen so if we
encounter
in the new philosophy one that has
unpaired one
that's probably the situation that's a
rare and we should give the message
that's what i suspect too and should
that be a literal message
or something by the predictive interface
saying a message
a message in this version a message
okay just says assuming so so what is
the form of this
that you would get in
you're proposing to get in in 12.2
this case right i enter this thing what
do i get out what is the input form in
that case
right so it's not my question yeah so
where you have uh
just five disconnected vertices no no
no this smile string molecule of string
5c
yes yes okay what would i get out in
that case
i like what you got earlier if you had
added the option
okay so let me let me do that now so
this is
now i would add the option include
hydrogen's arrow true
correct yes yes
okay so one of the arguments that you
guys gave me
before was oh it's it's too big a data
structure if you put all the hydrogens
in
right where did that argument go
so we come back with the next point from
jason
yeah the next point on down uh is that i
also want to make
the molecule uh an atomic
so that uh yeah
no i mean so you can't do what i just
did here with input form
well you can always use input form but
it's not
um it would be let's see uh a
an internal format that is easily
recognized by the system
as one that was created internally
um and it's just faster wait a minute so
you're proposing to make an incompatible
change in this version
so that and then you're going to make
another incompatible change
to no no no there's no second one
well but but the point is that if you
were going to make
this change well i see i see because you
still can read the thing in
all right so the goal is um
basically everybody in this group who
works with computers thought it was a
good idea do not have hydrogen it turns
out
for many chemists it's not the right
idea
yes but you want to basically do that
implicitly
by having your internal data structure
be something different
is that right right right so the input
form
would recover the hydrogens but the
internal data structure would not have
them in or some other crazy thing with
the internal data structure if we if you
scroll down it shows an example of what
i would uh
um you know yeah i love the the fact i
mean
so essentially if you do a random graph
or
get a graph from some situation some of
the times
what you when you look at its input form
it's uh what is it a sparse array and
it's got the word automatic in there
it's clearly an
internal format that is used internally
and so when i
yep i'm not a big fan of having the
input form molecule not
actually recover the input form i think
that you know recover and input form i
think that's an unfortunate feature of
graph
but i think that what is stored does not
necessarily have to be i mean input form
can do work
to get it into the format that it shows
do you understand what i'm saying right
i know i know
uh i've seen that done in the kernel
i've uh
okay not familiar i don't want them to
know about the implementation right i
mean we can clearly implement that
right we don't need to discuss it here
but
wait wait wait so you want to keep the
old form even
written to a file
because this is the scenario that jason
mostly tries to address where he reads a
million molecules from a file
so it's always if you read a million
molecules from a file you might as well
have a binary format that it keeps them
in
so it's always bothered me that for
tests i would keep a list of ten
thousand smile strings that i can pull
up rather quickly and it's all it's
faster to generate the molecules from
those smile strings than it is
to then re-read in the input don't you
why don't you make the input form be the
smile string then
why are you putting why are you making
this weird thing here but
but there's even less three of a human
than this this is completely unreadable
by a human
a smile string is at least obviously a
molecule
right i guess um the smile string seemed
to bridge too far for me
but okay look
look okay you've got two different
things going on here
first you think as i in fact argued
they can go back and um that that this
you know this removing hydrogens was
kind of a hack
right turns out it is kind of a hack so
we can't do it
right so now you're concerned that the
data structure you get is too big and
blobulous
right so
okay so let's think about this for a
second so
how would you get this explicit list
out of a molecule which is clearly a
useful list to have
how would you get that list well so you
so you can always call
molly so say you have mole one you can
always call molecule of
atom list of mall one comma bond list of
mole one
okay so that's the direct analog of
vertex list and edge list for graphs
right yes
okay also have to keep in mind that if
the molecule has 3d coordinates those
have to be carried along as well
and we've been kind of ignoring that so
far and just looking at atoms and bonds
and for me when a molecule has
coordinates you've got to have all the
hydrogens there as well
or if you're editing it and you remove
one of the hydrogens because you want to
do something
in its place things have to work
accordingly
and and not lose all the other
coordinates
no but i mean what you're saying is you
want a blob
here that represents the molecule okay
just like for a graph we just have a
blob that represents it you're not
expected to go inside
just like for a graph i mean you know so
here
right this is the analog for graph of
you know if i just say random graph
you know
okay i've got a random graph now
obviously it helps that it's just
displaying as a graph
and i've got a question here why why do
we display this
i mean i think doing this as a molecule
like this is fine but i'm i'm wondering
whether this should actually be made
smaller and whether we should have a
bigger picture here
no i mean it definitely needs work we
have cases where the aspect ratio of the
molecule itself
is so far from one that the summary
boxes look awful
in my opinion okay fine but but so so
what i would recommend here
is reformatting this so that it is
so that it has a much larger so it's
much more like a molecule plot
just like in the case of graphs we do
still have graph plot but mostly you
just see the
see the plot right now
on the other hand in the molecule case
you really do need to see the formula
because otherwise you often can't tell
what's going on am i making sense
and so for that i've always thought that
the the attached cell would be
nice when you click the molecule the
attached cell shows up down below
another i mean no no no no but
i think that we had this discussion i
think not everybody agreed with you and
this one yeah
that's true that's true okay so the
atoms and bonds thing i think that's
superfluous honestly to show at the top
level of the summary box
do you agree i think if we were going to
do something like that showing molecular
weight it seems more useful
no atoms and bonds are much easier to
digest because it's it's
integer information rather than real
okay yeah and the formula is
right so you both wait wait wait wait
i'm trying to understand
so you find both of those things useful
yes yes yeah everybody else in the group
besides myself likes the summary boxes
uh i i still think they need to
they it could be improved um that there
could be that it could be like
graph it could display as the molecule
plot but annotate it somehow with
yeah well why not why not i mean but why
not have something
which is pretty much like this like the
molecule plot but with a little
legend down at the bottom that says the
formula and um and says that the atom
counts stuff
so that would be right so then it would
be different than
not strictly the same thing you get back
from molecule plot
i mean no it wouldn't be the same thing
just like graph plot doesn't give you
exactly the same thing as the default
display form of graph graph plot gives
you a graphics object
this thing here with the purple border
is an actual graph object
do you see what i'm saying right but i
think i think i mean i
really liked it when we made the change
recently where the default behavior from
graphplot
basically matched because a lot of
people that's right that's right it's
right right but
but let me point out a graph plot is a
graphics object
this is not a graphics object do you
understand what i'm saying
absolutely right so so graph plot
of this has various different defaults
it probably has a different size
it has it is actually graphics see what
i'm saying
yes and and in the case of molecules
we could certainly have more of a
difference that is it could have more
annotation here
because clearly the formula is useful
right yes
okay by the way when you generate this
i mean this is clearly a shared data
structure so it's just pointer addition
adding to pointers
right there's not a copy of the atom of
h
thing i mean that's just in terms of the
way it's internally generated
that should be straightforward but this
is a big mess
this will add a lot more data
right right so so the the numerical form
i was showing below is
what i know i know i realize that i
understand that
i'm making a different point okay i'm
talking about this form here
right and how you avoid this getting
totally bloated
right internally not externally
well externally i don't see a real way
to avoid deplodedness
no i understand if you're going to write
this all out well there is one way which
is you could drop the bonds
these bonds going to the hydrogen atoms
i don't think you need to give them
explicitly do you i guess you do i guess
you could say
if you had um include hydrogen bonds or
something in here
as an option then it would say you know
well maybe you need to give them i mean
if i don't know i don't know you tell me
i mean the
bond list could give that but it doesn't
necessarily need to exist in this input
form
right so they don't so whether or not
that
like if you look at the expression
whether or not you see the h is there
should be immaterial it's when you ask
for the atom list or bond list you can
give the option include hydrogens
right you can get them or not right and
so so abstract
then the default is for bond
for atom list is the default to include
the hydrogens or not
it should be to include them okay yeah
if the users put them there
no no no no user hasn't put them there
the user has not put them there the user
gave a smile string
do you include them by default or not
when you ask them
you include them okay because otherwise
if you don't have the hydrogen
you have a different um
okay i mean one possibility would be
maybe to make pond a more complicated
thing
that allows like uh moody bonds like
moody line
so it would serve at least to be able to
solve for 60 pounds i wouldn't bother i
wouldn't bother i wouldn't bother
because
i think the correct thing to do is to
follow exactly the pattern that we have
for graph
okay the pattern we have for graphics
you said earlier you didn't like what
crafters
well i'm i'm changing my mind so if you
make input form of this you're fine with
this
okay let's look at this
yeah it's some garbage
right but not totally incomprehensible
the user can take that sparse array and
understand that that
is it's incomprehensible it's
incomprehensible
when looking at it yes but a user no
it's incomprehensible
doesn't matter nobody's going to use
this it doesn't matter
what this is i mean personally i'm not a
big fan of the exact way this looks
but it doesn't matter and you're not
going to argue that this is a user
you know this is one of these things
like it's a you know if you buy a
machine
it has no user serviceable parts so to
speak
and anybody who goes in and and you know
raw
extracts part three of this graph object
is simply going to
end up in trouble because in version 14
it's gonna change
right so i think it's okay to okay so
what you're proposing
is that molecule like graph is
accessed i mean
i don't know whether that's right so
this would actually
would solve the earlier problem that we
were talking about right so if yes of
course it would
the con if if you get back something
that is in the
old canonical format
and has imp has dangling hairs all over
the place
that tells you this yes that that would
do that yes
right but but there's a different point
which is
one of the things that
you know for graph for example
i had forgotten i was reminded yesterday
of the fact that you can give in a graph
when you say graph
you can give the
first argument can be nodes the second
argument to be edges
i always specify a graph by giving
the just an edge list
okay so it is a pity pedagogically
that there's no way to get out something
where you can explicitly see
this form especially as barbara's
pointed out when
when you have if you have
stereochemistry data as a third argument
right to reconstitute a thing you're
then
i mean i think the issue is right now we
have molecule modify and things like
that
probably that should get more explicitly
turned into things that are more like
the graph theory operations am i making
sense
rather than just one grab bag of
molecule modify
i i'm concerned that there isn't a
form okay so look what you guys
basically are saying is
you want to make a um
that's cool um
i don't think those are the right names
but anyway um
uh okay so in any case um
unless we're gonna have a similar thing
which is like a hash or something
for for i mean that's so much question
for the machine learning group whether
they want to have
some similar generalized fingerprint
function for other things
um
okay so back here
that's awful that's just awful
it's just awful you see it's not the
same thing with a graph because for a
graph you just say edge list
and you just say graph of the edge list
and you can reconstruct it
do you understand what i'm saying right
that's because the vertices are just
plain vertices they don't
have a character to them like hydrogen
carbon phosphorus
and we have to have that additional
information although
i will point out many people of our
users make mistakes when
when they have just a graph that they
create from an edge list because they
they assume that the vertices are are
numerical uh
exactly going from one up to n verts
uh but if they if they don't provide
them in that order in the edge list then
they
there are cases of confusion among the
users
right but the difficulty here is this
reconstitution thing we got to find a
better way to do this reconstitution
thing
i mean absolutely for what purpose i'm
not quite sure what you mean but
if the thing anyway doesn't exist why
would you want to build it
well you're saying what what i'm saying
is you want to do an operation on your
molecule
you you didn't look inside before and
you don't look inside
after yeah except that for graphs
it's very common to pull out the edges
do something to them
and then you know reconstitute the graph
you're claiming for molecules that is
the less common thing to want to do
that you don't want to you know for
molecules the moves you make have to be
done by chemistry at least in the
current state of the world
and therefore or by molecule modify
which has the extensive list of the
moves you might want to do
i know i know drawing utility
so it's funny here that you're talking
about pointers you mentioned pointers
above with the
the atom h and what we're talking about
here
i've rather like them and wish that we
had them more
in the uh uh wolfram language that no no
you don't even need them you don't need
them
because you've got a the thing is
implicitly turning itself into a point
what were you going to say
well just um let's see so i using
undocumented things in the uh the
prototype build i have it set up to
where that
the atoms that that come back from atom
list
are actually pointers that you cannot
that it says atom c is its input form
but you can ask it
how many connections it has and it knows
you can ask it what its like
i can't convince anybody that's
absolutely crazy yeah
no no let's let's not go there jason
please
that's kinda spooky okay
okay so one thing i would like to
suggest
is that we plan to take molecule modify
and you know we have a the
boy i mean if you're going to say split
it up like break off some like atom
add atom delete functions i love that
idea yeah i think we should do that
just like we have vertex add and so on
in in the case of graphs i think that's
what we should be looking at
um
now a good exercise okay so i think my
my point of view is go ahead and think
about
just making molecule be an opaque object
working like this okay change its in
change its output form to be more you
know emphasizing the image
make sense yes
and i think i'm okay with that um
fine try it see what you can do
um and and as you say
we're solving the problem of if you see
a molecule
in explicit molecule form not in this
digested form
then that is a clue that that was a pre
uh
you know include hydrogen's true default
case
right yes and i was planning uh to
put out a backlit update so that pre
12 0 and 12 1 could ingest the new
molecules and convert them to the that
would be good
i think you should have something in
here that is essentially versioning
information
even if it's implicit somehow
i don't quite know how to do that i mean
you could have a method option
here or something um i mean data set
mesh region they all have such stuff
inside
yeah what about the meta information
element jason
i tend to think of that as something the
user uh right right right there no one
might mess with that whatever mesh
region and all those things do you
should copy that
okay right so that we have versioning
information so we don't have this
problem again
um
there's really nice stuff here by the
way um thank you
it's really very impressive so here's a
test as far as i'm concerned okay
so you know i've been doing all this
stuff
with a random picture let's bring up a
random picture
well that's a random picture that's the
theorem network of euclid
um but that's not the most interesting
thing the most interesting thing is that
doing proofs
is like taking an expression and making
progressive modifications to it
it's like chemistry in other words
your sequence of you know
your way of doing a sequence of
essentially um
you know molecule modifies
you know which are sort of junior
versions of chemical reactions
is extremely similar to what's happening
inside these multi-way systems
which is extremely similar to what's
happening inside find equation or proof
just making any sense to anybody because
to me
yes yeah okay so a little bit less
convinced because
i think the one difference is that in
the proof case you have say a set of
axioms or things that you apply
and for them that is to converse
conservation law
but here there are conservation laws
which you kind of
break at every point no you can you can
spray hydrogen gas onto your thing
but clinic adding a hydrogen needs an
hydrogen from
any from from somewhere where an axiom
comes for free
actually michael okay so so here's the
thing
i have been actually quite deeply
confused about the difference between
equations
and transformations and axioms and so on
there are actually several different
ways to do this in math
um and they can all they all have nice
correspondences
i don't think this is a huge problem i
think that the question of whether
you um in some
but but but the basic idea is you know
what you've eventually got is
something where
you can imagine okay in one of these
i mean in your average where is it
um let me pull one up uh
hold on um
let me pull one up here um
you know some random thing like
like this
okay so we think of this
if we imagine this as a bunch of
potential chemical products
so this is each arrow here represents
some molecule modified that can be done
right not not really because
there is a basically for the molecule
modifier case there's an implicit error
where you either put something in or out
it's not just you take one and rewire it
no but but but look the result of
molecule modify
is you take one molecule here okay
and here here we've got let's take this
example here
okay we've taken one molecule and we've
got out a different molecule
yeah okay so this operation here
is like one of these arrows
and this molecule here that's this
molecule this one here is this molecule
let's say
in this case yes but if you would have
added an atom that wasn't there before i
feel like you have done something
different
well this is adding a bond that wasn't
there before no you
somehow got the atom itself that you
exit no i understand i understand
you're saying there's a physicality of
atom counting
that we're not necessarily taking
account of here
although we certainly yes what's
happening in this picture
is these are unary operations this is
you take this thing
you give an output right right
exactly you're saying that in another
case you've got another thing floating
around here and you combine it with this
okay basically diagrams
yes you mean potentials or something in
a fireman diagram
which allow me to break conservation
laws like momentum yes
okay so michael here's the point if you
look at find equational proof
it has the same thing going on it has if
you look at the graph that it makes
it is bringing in another piece it is it
is
essentially combining what it's doing is
it's applying
one okay so the different this is
it's quite confusing i'm glad you're
confused because i was very confused for
about two weeks about this
okay um i mean the difference is if
these things had eq
that there are three different forms i'm
about to write something about this and
then we'll all perhaps be less confused
um the um there are one thing is
you take that this axiom okay let's say
this
thing had an equal sign in it okay that
was a
an assertion that had an equal sign in
then this
this edge is itself just like an
assertion with the equal sign in
okay now a different way of thinking
about it is
that you but basically basically the
point is that there's ways
that there are different representations
of this some in which
you are taking what two theorems you're
taking one theorem
and you're applying another theorem to
that theorem to get a third theorem
that's what you do in implication right
a a implies b
b right and that that implicational form
i suspect is more similar to
you wheel in another set of atoms and
combine them
okay let me rephrase my thing like if i
have a set of axioms
or the string rewriting i can generate
infinite many different things by never
needing something new
you can't generate infinitely new
molecules if you don't also supply
infinitely i understand it's a question
whether you have a closed system or an
open system
exactly but but i think that it's that
there are plenty of cases in chemistry
where what you're interested in some
synthesis thing is
is an open system if i'm not mistaken
that is that that's right that's right
for synthesis planning it does not have
to be closed
if you were trying to model something
that was happening in the laboratory and
we had you know
so many grams of this and so many grams
of that to start with and when we finish
we've got to have so many plus so many
grams of something or some combination
of things at the end
because it's a closed system right okay
so
yeah right so this theory here can
certainly be open would put
you know the multi-way system right so
okay so then
then okay so here's here's what i'm the
reason i'm bringing this up
okay is because i want the design to be
such that this would all just fit
beautifully together
right because what
okay so one thing i realized which i was
super embarrassed to have not realized
before
is that uh there is a really simple
function which i can call find replace
path
that given a set of rules will just find
the sequence of rules that you need to
apply to get for example from
a b to aaa right so
it you can either generate the graph
explicitly and then say find shortest
path
right or you can simply say if i were to
pull this in hold on one second here um
this is fine string replace path
okay so find string replace path would
say this in here
right i would just say take those rules
and it's essentially
virtually generating a graph so so if i
say
find and this is you're going to see why
this is relevant in a moment
okay find string replace path
of this let's say we go from a b to
i don't know to aba
okay so that's the path so that is that
is a
virtually generated path right i could
have explicitly generated the whole
graph
and then done a fine shortest path to
get that path but instead what i
you know that's equivalent to saying
find shortest but you you all understand
this right
yes find shortest path and what does it
do if you give it one it
uh it can never reach it hangs forever
uh find replace path um yeah
it has it has a it has limits here that
are called
max steps max item's time constraint um
now we actually have a new function
called find counter example
find equation or counter example which
can prove that it can't be got to
i saw this in the wfr today right
um okay so here but but the but the
but the kind of the lame version of it
is okay so there we go
all right so now
and this is very similar but not quite
the same
as find equational proof
and this isn't quite working this isn't
quite the same right
so if i were to say find equational
proof of a b
equals equals aba i don't know if this
will work yet
let's take a look notice the unfortunate
different argument order here because
the axioms go second and find equational
proof
yeah it doesn't doesn't oh shoot oh yeah
because this is all screwed up
yes um i this doesn't work yet but but
then
this will generate a proof right which
has a slightly different format than
these things
but that proof actually what that proof
is showing
is it shows the path basically and then
it shows stubs of the path
so if i say
this this isn't as irrelevant as you
think it is by the way there's a whole
discussion oh god why is this still
broken
this is another thing that's still
broken
bob is it doesn't this look like a
retrosynthetic analysis
uh whether it's retro or not
um it it would be applicable yes
but we're generally doing the forward
direction here
yeah uh retrosynthesis is generally
bigger steps to go backwards to find
your general route your starting
materials you
start with the product and you go to the
materials
right so that that is that is given this
string
you want to know what is a path from the
root to that string
so that by the way is again
unfortunately
and michael i was so confused about this
i think i have finally unscrambled my
confusion but i won't know that until
i've written about it
in some cases you start from true and
you are deriving all true statements
okay right and that's that's the analog
of what you say is how do i get
to this thing here oh i need to apply
these axioms you know heat it
shake it whatever else um
oh gosh what is the command key i never
use the command key
to um um well to complete it command
shift k
or to a template
you know what this is doing when i did
what i thought would do this on my
keyboard
it caused my display to go blank
that's not what i wanted i want it i
want the i just want the oh gosh
i'm this is so frustrating
it's amazing how much one starts relying
on these little user interface
elements okay so what i wanted to show
you was
um
oh i mean take a random proof graph here
okay okay so this
rather confusingly is similar to but not
quite the same so this essentially has
one path
it should have one path that isn't
dotted lines so those are the axioms at
the top
these things here there should be i'm
now very confused about how this is
working yeah i think look i think here
you go here's the solid line
that goes from the hypothesis
down to the conclusion right and all the
other stuff here
is essentially prepping lemmas
to use okay so those are what is the
analog of a lemma in chemistry
um so you know it's a partial thing that
you prepare
that is a a thing that will be fed in
to put into the synthesis so it's a it's
a my product a by product
yeah but it's
it's it's what you're doing it's not the
the byproduct with somebody
something that comes out it's something
you prepare where you say make this
thing
and then put it go ahead i would say it
could be thought of as
state variable conditions so temperature
pressure it could be thought of as the
solvent
the aqueous you know the whatever
environment they're in gas phase
you're building your building blocks
basically you're making a number of
building blocks and then
gluing them together uh in a particular
sequence
and do you do that almost commonly in
chemical synthesis yes
yes yes yes all the time you assemble
from intermediates the bigger stuff and
then big
big bigger things bring
you bring them together to make even
bigger things yeah intermediates is
another term
or building blocks those are the two
common terms okay
all right okay so then then what this is
saying is
so a lemma is one of these building
blocks basically
that you're then going to apply to get
whatever you get here
okay so what i'm asking is what i'd like
to see
and maybe i mean um
is you know
what ultimately what you want is this
this thing here well actually this is
not a good example this is
sorry what am i asking for i i think i
think the situation is more complicated
because a very variation of what i said
earlier like even with the building
blocks
you don't make the raw building blocks
with a couple of open
bonds you say have two molecules and
then put them together and split a
little bit up so i think it's
much more this open system paradigm
where things come in
all the time and go all the time
let me show you something find replace
path okay so let me show you this
okay so that's showing you essentially
what you do at each step
right that's the that's the instructions
for the synthesis
if that makes sense
although this isn't showing you
it's not necessarily showing you where
you apply those rules at each step right
it's saying
this is the rule at each step but there
could be multiple applications of a rule
at a given step
and this is simply one of the paths
okay so you need to see the whole thing
here you need to have
there's a there's a full representation
that gives you um the the location at
which this application is made which is
very similar to this in fact if we do
this
with official multi-way system it will
give you that information
so in other words it's it's going to be
something essentially identical to this
it's going to say um apply this
substitution
at this place replace the atom
which atom are you replacing or i mean
well in this case you're just replacing
a single atom but i assume you can
you can glue in a particular place you
remove an atom
and you add some some uh ligandy thing
on instead right yeah in the regular
organic synthesis world
the reagents would actually be doing
that when you're
uh coupling two intermediates together
or two building blocks for example with
an ester linkage
you end up removing a molecule of water
in the process you know an o h
from one side and an h from the other
okay so so let me ask this question if i
if i were to
you know if you have one of these all
possible syntheses
does that get considered in chemistry i
mean that must happen if you just
you know take a bunch of molecules and
you've got various things that are going
on with them
you know if you just got a pot of stuff
yeah those are called chemical
rearrangements i've been trying to study
that a little bit since the summer
school but haven't gotten very far
yeah and uh there's all this field
called combinatorial chemistry where
yeah it's kind of like that you mix a
bunch of stuff try to take the products
and see what those products do
right no although i thought
combinatorial chemistry was much more of
a
a um something where you have a library
and you're trying to do it
right it's more controlled and you end
up with
many different things in many different
pots so
let me ask a naive question if if i'm
you know like oil or something or
something you know when you have i i
mean i know so little chemistry but i
mean when you have one of these things
you just
you're just mixing together carbon and
hydrogen and you heat it up in some way
and various different lengths of
polymers form and so on
what how do people think about that how
do people you know what
what you know you're just you're just
taking this random collection of
of things and you're applying an
operation and you get a diversity
you know of different for example
lengths of polymers
amounts of branching those kinds of
things what is that
it's a one part something but i'm not
sure what you would call it
yeah i i was just gonna say it's a
it was a first year experiment that
didn't go right
yeah i mean it's like the the you're not
yuri bradley but
the uh the european miller experiment
yes yuri miller experiment yeah
yeah right but i mean i i think okay but
so one pot
synthesis is is the is the is the
general term for those kinds of things
is that right
yeah yeah and hopefully you have a major
product and not
a giant commish we try to avoid the
complex mixtures as much as possible we
want the large yields
right right yeah in other words you want
to follow a particular path
in the synthesis thing yeah right but
but so
in uh see the reason i'm
okay the thing is we're going to have a
really pretty nice set of essentially
theorem proving capabilities
that i mean i understand that actual
chemical synthesis has more complicated
issues it has all kinds of reaction
rates
and all kinds of things like this but
i'm just trying to understand you know
given that we've got a pattern for
designing
these kinds of things where there are
many possible changes that can be made
type thing i'm just trying to understand
actually it occurs to me that we should
have
um yeah
i'm i'm sorry i'm just thinking about we
don't really have a graph
modify function
the only thing we have is the whole you
know wolfen model
um you know hypograph transformation
stuff which is pretty
pretty general um but it only
yes anyway i'm just i'm sorry i'm
thinking out loud here and we should um
go ahead
after so after all this i mean the next
step is
to look at a chemical reaction as a data
structure where you have
a full atom mapping between uh reactants
and products and um and let's see i mean
so
before i arrived here uh one of the one
of the
people who was working at alpha for for
a time he
was looking at this uh this paper about
a chematica which is
touching a lot of the points that you
are
where where you have this uh this
collection of graph transformations
and um and it's all and it was really
trying to predict uh one
one pod synthesis routes um and we're
going to
we're developing the tools that we can
look back at
okay so one of the things that's an
interesting issue is
like for example one thing we don't
typically have in the language
is we have something where you say make
a transformation to this expression
okay fine the transformation you know we
say replace the transformation is
applied somewhere in that expression
if we ask the question where did that
transformation get applied
we don't have a particularly good way to
represent that
see what i'm saying so in other words in
these strings
i'm just saying i'm using these rules
but i'm not saying which
a well i probably weren't very many a's
here but which
a was that string
you know which of the two a's did i
apply
that transformation to see what i'm
saying and you're going to need that for
the chemistry case
right so so the ideally like uh so we'll
be able to deal with uh partially mapped
chemical reactions but i
in the ideal case uh we'll have a full
atom mapping
and and you'll have cases where the it
there are multiple matches and so the uh
so that's
when you apply that reaction to a list
of chemicals
you would then get back a list of lists
right exactly but so i mean my point
i don't even know in chemical synthesis
right it must be a problem
if you have two such and such groups and
you do a reaction that applies itself to
a such and such
group you're going to get you know both
of them both will react
unless you've protected one specifically
and you can
do that that's that's an art in itself
of of
different protecting groups being used
appropriately to control your synthesis
in the end
yes but this gets back to those
pre-building blocks you would take your
molecule
protect i.e turn off one of the groups
that you don't want to react
that you have multiple of and then you
do the reaction that you want to change
the thing of interest
and then you go back and unprotect the
thing that you
wanted to make sure it didn't change
right and because the reaction that does
the protection
is very specific it can distinguish the
two
groups that uh are there you know in the
original structure
um right so what you're saying is
what you're trying to do is your goal is
to have
you know a single path here and um
uh you know which you know in which
everything in which the pathway
is basically one on that path and zero
and all other parts
to maximize the yield failure yeah yeah
right
yield the the yield is going to be the
pathway of the path that leads you to
the product you want
yes right and um uh
so so okay so then
a protection a protecting group in the
multi-way graph
is something which basically i i hate to
make these analogies
but it's the analog of a space-like
singularity in the
in i mean it's a thing for which
some something has to be set up so that
it cannot have
rules applied to it yeah okay you know
you're basically taking one of those b's
and turning it into a c temporarily
and then you restore it back to its b
character afterwards
yeah you give it a distinct a
distinguishing feature so
it doesn't get touched right i
understand
but one of the things that you're doing
in chemical synthesis which is a little
different from what you're doing here
is here you have a set of rules and you
just say go
whereas um the um
uh you know the difference
in chemistry as you say for a while i'm
gonna heat it then i'm gonna cool it
then i'm gonna do this then i'm gonna do
that
so the chemistry has has sort of
different
rules at different stages so to speak
um yeah we don't but there's different
yeah
these different rules only determine
which rule to apply
we just have a large set of words and
much of our draw
yes i understand i understand i mean it
um
so is it true i mean the number of steps
it's like 30 steps or something is
this kind of the limit of current
synthesis
technology is that about right is it
more than that
for some things it's certainly more than
that uh
there are protein synthesizers uh
nucleotide synthesizers
that can go many many more steps than
that in good yield but
it's a very restricted set of chemistry
and how many more steps and in what case
what kind of case
they can put together hundreds of amino
acids to make a protein
and then and then there's also the issue
of
a convergent what you call a convergent
synthesis versus a linear synthesis
usually when you with the convergent
synthesis you can manage more steps
because you're building
you're slowly building uh bigger things
and then combining big things into even
bigger things
right yeah okay so for example if you're
doing an oligonucleotide or something if
you're
creating one of those you're saying that
that's like a synthesis reaction
where that's like synthesis but you're
going and chugging along
and adding base pairs or something
adding adding amino acids or whatever is
that right i mean is that that what you
mean by you know
that's the case where you think of like
when you're creating some polym
you know heteropolymer type thing yeah
you're able to do but are there other
cases where you're able to do a lot more
for practical reasons in in reasonable
yields
yeah it's probably on the order of 20 or
30 total reactions
is what you typically see reported in
the synthetic chemistry literature at
least organic
for some arbitrary natural product or
something like that
that's not a polymer okay fair enough
all right anyway look this is all
irrelevant but i i just wanted to
make this point because it would be nice
to have some sort of uniformity to our
way of doing
you know string replacements molecule
modifies
graph replacements et cetera etc etc
and i also feel like there's a i mean
what i really realized is that this
replace path mechanism um
the um um
uh is um
you know logic programming is sort of a
story of replace path
find replace path that is it's
what sequence of moves do you have to
make to get from here to there and so on
and and all of the various and actually
we have pretty efficient stuff for doing
that
and you know i thought we needed some
specialized logic programming capability
we really don't
this is a clean way to present it and i
think you know potentially relevant for
the chemistry thing
okay comment on our live stream use
pattern rule matching for rule selection
the pattern is instead of functional
groups present in the reaction mixture
right yes the pattern is um
uh is pattern is analog to functional
group is that is that right i mean that
that's something where you can
substitute in
something else in that position yeah
yeah
yes well very interesting okay
stephen have the multi-weight tools
progressed to working on graphs yet in a
general way
absolutely wait wait a minute so the
the multi-way yes absolutely you can
apply them to hyper graphs
bob i remember the paper i sent around a
while ago
yeah yeah i i've been working on a
similar one
yeah they treat the actions as graphic
writing rules
right yeah but so far uh
the the the last i pl i worked with a
multi-way stuff it's on a hyper graph
and not
a graph with undirected edges or excuse
me not a hyper graph it's a directed
graph
and i thought that's a good point yes
yes yes that's a good point we should
we should make multi-way graph work
multi-way system
work with ordinary graph objects i agree
that that that would be i mean it's not
difficult to do but but it's
right now but it's it's um i mean you
know we we had done one meeting on how
to make multi-way graph main
multi-weight system mainstream um in the
system and i think we need to do another
one it's a fairly complicated function
um but uh it's amazing how
how unified all of these different
issues are okay i'm just um
i mean and what is there any meta
statement
um uh
um you know when you're
asking about chemical synthesis so i
mean the reason i'm asking this i'm
you know i've been working on this
mathematics stuff where whether what one
is trying to do is to make general
statements about the structure of these
multi-way systems and the possible
proofs you can get and so on
what general statements are there about
these kind of
uh reaction pathway things
um are there any general statements in
chemistry that people make i mean other
than
other than we want to get a particular
path because that's the thing that gets
us decent yield
is there any i mean like like for
example
um yeah i guess people don't deal with
that
you know in chemistry like in
programming you don't want the ambiguity
of getting lots of different things
you want a single path yes generally
that's right yeah
we do sort of abstract the edges in the
sense that we have families of reactions
that we know
if your molecule has a particular shape
or
functional group then then we can you
know we can talk about whole classes of
reactions
so i don't know if that's quite what
you're thinking about maybe
it's not not quite the same thing but i
think i mean
generally look in programming
you know this is like a representation
of a
of an asynchronous parallel programming
type thing
and people find it very hard to think
about this and people generally
in writing code try to reduce it to a
single path
my guess is that i mean in
in and and like in chemistry
in a distributed computing system you
have no guarantee what's going to happen
when
in other words you you can't um um it's
all asynchronous so
yeah so and you have to what is the
avoidance or race condition in chemistry
that's your protecting group
thing you're protecting that that avoids
you know knowing which is going to
happen in which order
avoiding the ambiguity of of different
ordering of different things happening
i suspect your protecting group thing is
exactly analogous
to something like one of these locks
that's that's like a lock
in distributed computing yeah a luck is
a good analogy for a protecting group
yes
yeah um yeah one thing i i'd like to say
about this multi-way system though if
you step back
and look at something like biosynthesis
of terpenoids
you start out with something very simple
at top like pharmacol
and you can produce at the bottom lots
and lots of different
sesquiterpenes not that a single
organism produces them all but
if you look at all the different
pathways of
related organisms well that sounds
interesting what is that
what is that tell me what that is well i
don't know how to spell those words
biosynthesis i can spell that of course
okay starting
of sesquiterpenes 15 carbon natural
products made up of three isoprene units
and you start with pharnasol or
pharnacil pyrophosphate
which is mostly linear it's got three
methyl extra methyl groups on it
these are these the pheromone-like
things that are used by various animals
pheromones are some things that are
produced yes uh but there are
monoterpenes flavorings and and
fragrances
menthol camphor and things like that
um and in sesquiterpenes uh
a lot of them are um antibiotics and
sorts of things they're produced by
fungi and plants and they
they're it's all secondary metabolism
and they're generally related
to uh protecting the atom the organism
from
predation by other organisms
chemicals sometimes called yeah
but so so what you're saying here is
when when you do biosynthesis of these
things
that i mean is that is there some giant
uh
pathway that like a giant sort of
multi-weight graph right
and and some organisms follow some path
part of the pathway because of the
enzymes that they have
and other organisms have a slightly
different pathway because of their
enzymes
and a lot of this has been worked out um
you can actually
see some of the evolutionary
relationships of the or of a collection
of organisms that have
related compounds yeah i looked at a lot
of this stuff from my uh
doctoral work
about this this seems quite interesting
i mean okay i'll i'll dig some stuff up
and send it to right
so in principle one could end up with a
picture like this where every node is a
molecule
yes and
okay well that'll be interesting
okay all right we should go to different
different meetings here but um
uh all right so i think i mean this
chemistry stuff we're gonna need to meet
again but it's looking good and i think
we have a direction here
um all right thank you
thank you okay thank you